olá a todos sua alta que quer falar
andar que seja muito enfim jamais um
vídeo e os estragos e que faz night at
freddy's 2 e hoje nós vamos ficar em
noite que vocês tanto pedem que é que
esta noite mas quando cheguei aqui só
não fiquei muito surpreendido porque
isso não só tem a noite 2020 ou seja os
quatro animais tronics antigos apenas
como também tem mais questão night que
têm o gene matronic sinopse que new and
shine pois têm outras condições que tem
oponente golborne novo e só foxy tem
muitas variações equipe cíveis pessoal
tem muitas que estão no haiti
mas as principais que eu quero são mesmo
ampliá lá até 2020 ou seja os 4m tronics
antigos e à noite gol de fred que
basicamente são todos os animais sony
inclusive o gol de fred todos é nível 27
anos vão parecer muito mas muitas vezes
hoje eu vou jogar à noite 2020 ou seja
vão apenas o terceiro gene matronic
santics mas muitas muitas vezes porque o
santo é de nível 20
se vocês derem um grande e forte apoio
pessoal ainda hoje o tento colocar a
noite kudrin fred eu não prometo que vou
conseguir passar porque ela é mesmo
muito difícil eu ainda não fui ver o
youtube keta conseguiu passar que não
conseguiu passar eu não sei não faz
idéia sexta no tempo é impossível os tem
algum truque para se passar ou assim não
faz a mínima e daí mas sei que é muito
difícil porque são todos animatronics
nível 20
é complicado é complicado mas por hoje
pessoal vamos apenas jogar aqui esta
noite também deve ser muito complicada
mas são só quatro animatronics mas é bom
deixar conversa pessoal deixa o nosso
apoio até pessoal e não tenho certeza se
você pegasse um pai por ser eu não sei
se eu estava ali na lista dos quatro
neurônios mas eu acho que não por isso
eu não vou preocupar com o palhaço
talvez eu vou te fazer um teste só pra
ver se o palhaço me parece eu não sei se
era um animal eletrônica estava incluído
na que os quatro mas eu acho que sim
eu acho que o saci da caixa
ok ok eu acho que vamos saltar em cima
só destrói só o texto prevê visita que o
separação não é pressa parece pronta
para essa pressa ok ok só então o final
de 2014 animatronics mas de opiáceos um
filho eu treinar um time do tamanho
agora sim saber que existem que os e
palácio por ter mais atenção e buscar
com mais calma
bora lá o que não consigo explicar as
luzes vão escolher portando acusa raposa
já que os raposas vai embora da raposa
vai te embora já a a ir embora eu não
quero aqui não vamos saltar em cima né
não não é uma fred só não garanto que
vou conseguir passar esta noite vou
tentar ao máximo
eu não garanto é meia noite está a ser
muito difícil já que o sol aparecer
muito calma e palhaços e apoiar sempre
na se você pegasse não faça por favor
ainda falo da raposa meu metabolismo
pode demorar muito vocês também já me
disseram que os raposas não quer fazer
uma aula e ouvir alguém dentro da
ventilação a pouco meu isso não pode
acontecer porque não há seguranças não
acusei do balão nem outra raposa neon
que está dentro da ventilação na uel
soma trabalha aqui eu sou uma
trabalhadora que eu acho que fui então
acho que não vai estar ai ai jogos do
capeta
vou seguir a minha fantasia é isso
lá está a chorar hoje tenho duas
lágrimas jesus é fantasma não chores vai
lá quem dá comida que sou eu não é
estúpido ou etanol vapor a apple se a
destino do mel etc
não sem no chão eu acho que vocês
ninguém vai me faltava que o palhaço é
já que ninguém
o boi já cá e não condicionada mas vamos
lá então tentar outra vez só porque você
consegue passar esta noite nas dicas
inertes nas drogas leves bruno roque
pessoal são duas por furto em manhã não
aguentei até às duas da manhã
calma lá na posição de causar deposição
avançado o campo foi muito rápido agora
ainda a nossa quando duas da manhã e só
vou conseguir vou conseguir
já apareceram muitos sapatos muitos é
que pode dizer que josé campos ainda não
vi muitas vezes mas já tô estar aqui
os outros dois porque eles vão crescer
20 este cada um supostamente é isso o
cae está tranquilo tranquilo ou gato ela
agora pode conseguir com muita calma e
com muita tranquilidade e com muita
atenção não vai conseguir passar esta
porcaria
o asp lento acho que agora vai focar
são três da manhã pessoas apesar do
resultado da noite meu isto é muito o
santos enfrenta agora porque quase
sempre lento e só conseguimos passar até
as três também é eu estou começando a
ficar irritado porque ator que há algum
tempo
josé pinto e josé coelho acho que tem um
caso de um dia porque aparecem sempre o
mesmo foi que em tempo atrás do outros
jovens como ele atrasou para a casa do
pai meu lá lá
o caraças agora o pessoal sai por cerca
de 30 agora é encarar essa desculpa
pronto pronto e todos comigo porque não
devo falar mal dos alimentos ônibus
enquanto chove isso eu não sei porque
você pode apanhar um jovem os
sentimentos porque este jogo é do
demônio
o fax deputado já montado em um pulso
mel já não consegue ser rápido já não
consegue ser rápido montado no pulso já
montado no pulso e não consegui ser
rápido
o grupo chamado muito pulso faca
a faca
cinco da manhã
a chamada 80 o público só assim vocês
não tem noção das duas que eu ter agora
hum
tô bem melhor e consegui passar a haver
sol é ser empecilho tive que muito tempo
na cabeça do chip pinturas do que há
muito tempo filhos dá mais chupa e lá
dentro
cansaço estou aqui há muito tempo ainda
vai no entanto pouco sério esta mão
aquela que está a controlar o controlo
eu normalmente os ninguém para o
controlo e e sério o tendão do dedo
passou uma equipa ao pulso é duro passar
a noite aqui então estas duas estrelas
que indica que nós já conseguimos passar
esta questão night
nós temos mais temos muitas mais mas o
que eu quero mesmo passar o pessoal eu
acho que vou conseguir com muito treino
mas eu vou conseguir que é passar esta
questão night go tem fred que com todo o
cinema tronics a nivel 20 mas quando eu
gosto pessoal aic favorito fiquem bem
até a próxima
o